these days the most stunning thing about
capitalism is the drive it seems to have
to self-destruct what an amazing reality
that a country
where the biggest defense establishment
in the world
cannot defend itself against the culvet
19
virus half as well as dozens of
countries
with much less military and many fewer
resources
the fundamental purpose of government
and this is something that
conservatives and liberals both agree on
is to keep the people safe and secure
if you think about the cdc's annual
budget it's about 11 billion dollars a
year
in comparison one defense contractor
alone
lockheed martin earns almost 50 billion
dollars a year
from federal government contracts that's
about five times as much
as the united states spends on the cdc
all
the money the united states spends on
jets
satellites aircraft carriers cyber
warfare capabilities
it would total almost one trillion
dollars a year
mr president i believe in a strong
military
but we cannot continue to give more
money
to the pentagon than it needs
we are spending more on the military
than the next
11 nations combined that's russia china
uk france you name it more than all of
them combined
we are talking about the need to defeat
our most
immediate adversary right now
an adversary that has taken in recent
months
over a hundred and twenty thousand
american lives
and that of course is the coronavirus
when the coronavirus crisis began
defense contractors
sought assurance from the federal
government that they would be
protected and taken care of even if
their workers
couldn't go to the office or do their
jobs
because of mandated social distancing
requirements
the federal government committed to
supporting
major defense contractors in the united
states
because it considered them strategically
important corporations
the defense industry is relatively
immune to the facilities of the economy
in a few days to regroup lockheed
surged up to 380 today
major american defense contractors are
for-profit
publicly traded corporations and there's
a real moral hazard here
because no matter what they do the
federal government is always going to
have their back and support them
in other words these companies
and i'm talking about lockheed martin
and northrop grumman
for all intents and purposes
are governmental agencies over 90
percent
of their revenue comes from the
taxpayers
a plane from the u.s backed saudi-led
coalition struck
a bus carrying them dozens died
munitions experts tell cnn this was a
u.s
made mark mk 82 bomb this number here
denotes lockheed martin
one of the top us defense contractors
and lockheed martin isn't the only major
u.s defense contractor
there are dozens of corporations that
make billions and billions of dollars a
year
northrop grumman raytheon boeing
these are major companies that make
billions of dollars
that have been not much used to us
during the coronavirus pandemic
which represents one of the greatest
existential threats the united states
has faced
perhaps in its history as it's achieved
increasingly apocalyptic proportions in
this country
there still doesn't seem to be any sort
of initiative to
get something like test and trace go in
so that we could
reopen without compromise and safety
like the fact that still not going now
kind of makes me think we live in a
failed state
we have uh research and development into
planes that the military does not need
but we can't get gloves and gowns and
plastic face shields to
our healthcare workers in the middle of
a pandemic so
from a manufacturing standpoint from a
priority standpoint
public health has been left by the
wayside for far too long
and i think when we come out of this
pandemic we need a reorganization
we need a re-prioritization of our
values
and that also includes funding into
public health we have
an aversion to sort of public health and
to
health overall in the us because somehow
got thought of as a handout a giveaway
you know there's something sort of
socialist about the idea of providing
basic services to your population and so
reframing it as sort of a national
security priority is is one thing
but i don't think it gets at the sort of
aversion that many politicians in the us
have to social spending and health
spending in particular
i think about you know how easy that
that last military funding bill went
through congress before this all started
it like
bipartisan there was just no breaks on
it whatsoever
it's like it's always you know how can
we pay for this and it's never it's
never with militarization
the 2020 national defense authorization
act
is about making sure our war fighters
have the tools resources and equipment
you need to fight
and to win all the time to win we don't
have enough masks we don't have enough
gowns
we're making our military stronger and
more powerful than ever before
we don't have enough gloves we don't
have enough nasal swabs
and if you saw where we started from
not so long ago we don't have enough
vials for
tests we're short on reagents you'd
really be amazed i want to thank
everybody but i want to
also thank those great companies that
really designed made this equipment
because i have seen it and i've seen
much of it in action and i've frankly
never seen anything like it in my life
so i just want to congratulate you all
because together we are protecting our
people
our values our traditions and our
glorious
american flag
if the horrific pandemic we are now
experiencing
has taught us anything it is that
national security means
a lot more than building bombs
missiles jet fighters tanks
submarines nuclear warheads and
other weapons of mass destruction
national security also means
doing everything that we can
to make sure that every man woman and
child
in this country lives with dignity
and security the slogan for our time can
be
and should be we can do better than
capitalism we can take care of our needs
meet our needs and do without the
subordination
of everything to the private profit of a
few